hey youtubers is Charlie in the Walking
Dead finale totally delivered on the WTF
and left things on this cliffhanger that
really demands that we bookmark season 5
episode 1 in our calendars which is like
seven months away even though we got
most of the things that we thought we
were going to get there were still a few
surprises and things that they held back
on as well as a few surprise cameos that
we're really awesome so before we dive
into the WTF quick shout out for the
giveaway because I hit 150,000
subscribers just as the episode was
starting I'm so happy and you guys have
been so awesome
I'm upping it to three gift cards that
I'm giving away all you have to do is be
a subscriber and leave a comment below
but I'll be announcing who those winners
are in the Q&A video tomorrow and I'll
also be posting a season 5 predictions
video so let's just go ahead and wait
right into the blood but what I'm going
to do is my top 5 WTF moments and then
do a post-mortem review on the entire
season you know as well as this episode
here we go number 5 Hershel flashbacks
if you had trouble pinpointing whenever
these scenes were happening it was
basically in the time between the season
3 finale and the start of season 4 about
two months after Woodbury I love the
Hershel and Patrick cameos may they rest
in pieces the bigger theme of the
episode was who am i and Chandler Riggs
you know as Carl even said who are we I
really felt like they were trying to
foreshadow Rick's line from the comics
when he says we are The Walking Dead but
it never came maybe they'll drop that
next season whenever the second half the
cliffhanger picks up who else laughed
though whenever Rick walked up to
Patrick playing with the Legos and he
just made that face and then went over
to Carl who was just cleaning his gun
like a pro Chandler Riggs has actually
grown quite a bit since season 3 so he
actually looked way different I bet that
they waited till recently to shoot these
scenes rather than shoot them at the
beginning of the season and did anyone
else feel like it was almost Herschel's
fault that Rick became this ineffectual
farmer Rick you know the one that Carl
got so mad at for not being the badass
he was in this episode it was Noble I
totally don't blame her shell or
anything but you could see how much he
was trying to convince him to start
living like a pacifist you know and less
like a monster that Michonne and Carl
kind of thought that they were turning
into or the Michonne thought she was and
on to number 4 I'm just a monster -
Carla Michonne stock was so brutal
especially when Misha and explained the
rest of her origin story with her son
Andre and Mike and Terry it was really
hard to tell whether she turned them
into pets to punish them or to punish
herself for not being there to save them
but I really think she was just
punishing herself it was also really
nice that she acknowledged the mechanics
of using those pets to camouflage
herself
maybe they'll use that again in the
future Carl was just explaining his
existential crisis and how it was the
source of tension between him and Rick
he's really just upset with himself for
thinking he's a monster as opposed to
the Lego fanboy that he thinks that Rick
wants him to be you'd almost say that
about any of the characters in the
episode you know especially Daryl Rick
Michonne and Carl you know are you a
monster or are you a Lego fanboy slash
fangirl feel free to let me know which
one you are in the comments below and
number three
welcome to terminus there are times when
characters do crazy stupid things and
there are times when you just feel so
proud for how careful they're being or
how smart I can honestly say I was proud
of Rick for this entire episode you can
clearly tell that he has learned from
past events and isn't going to trust
anyone ever again you know dust backdoor
entry I feel like that idea you know you
can't trust anyone with just hammered
home whenever they pass through that
creepy shrine and it said never again
never trust up on the wall as much as
terminus has been a mystery the second
half of this season I feel like we all
kind of agree that those are not good
people even when we finally met Gareth
he was just way too disarming cut to
literally disarming but we have to say
it he's totally not the governor Scott
Gimple and Robert Kirkman made a big
point of saying that there would be no
negan or other big bad like him for a
long time they just needed a lot of
space between two mega villains I just
can't say it enough though Rick was on
his [ __ ] in this episode no [ __ ]
eyes of the hawk where did you get that
watch cut to number two reunion in Trank
ra the biggest surprise here was that
everyone was still okay with all their
limbs attached big asterisks though
where the f is Beth for now we can just
say that everyone is still in the
condition that they entered in let me
know if you disagree but we can all just
say what we're thinking here cannibals I
actually cheered really loud whenever
Rick slapped that plate out of Carl's
hands do not eat the people meats
just can't come back from that it's not
like this is an episode of Hannibal we
won't get confirmation though till
season five but I'm expecting them to
tie everything up in that first episode
fingers crossed
which is only seven months away no big
deal we can all just write terminus
fanfiction until then but please no
creepy cannibal sex stuff which actually
leads me to my number one WTF moment
Joe's group is totally the Marauders
from the comics it went down almost
exactly how we expected if you're not
familiar with the comics in issue 57 the
Marauders were just a couple of people
that sexually assaulted Carl and just
tried to kill them
Rick ended up biting a giant chunk out
of one of their necks and brutally
revenge killed the one that assaulted
Carl the difference was is that it was
me shown holding Carl on the show and it
was Abraham in the comic but that shot
was exactly the same as it was in the
comic even though I totally expected
this to happen it was still so hard to
watch I had to look wait just a little
bit but I did like how they kind of
jumped around in time like they showed
us that end moment first and then jump
back to the beginning did anyone else
think that it was strange that Rick
seems so fazed in that moment we saw him
first you know right after the opening
teaser and then when Daryl sat down he
just seemed totally fine
Redbeard full of blood I actually wanted
to start calling him red beard like he
was almost a different character at that
point after that he felt so much more
action-oriented and driven that he has
all season long he actually said the
same thing that Tyreese said to Carol
after the whole Lizzie WTF episode we do
what we do because of them to keep them
safe whenever Rick said it he was
talking about Carl specifically and
Tyreese was just talking about Judith so
now it's your turn let me know what was
your biggest WTF moment was it the
Marauders or was it that cliffhanger
like I said I will be doing the Q&A
video tomorrow as well as season 5
predictions so we can talk all about
Beth all about terminus cannibals all
about baby Judith Carol and Tyreese so
we can cover everything but here's my
quick post-mortem on season 4 as well as
my review of this episode just let me
stop my hands from shaking just a little
bit overall I do give the finale an a
just for a character development of
course I was disappointed that they left
so many big questions unanswered like
where's Beth when are they going to
reveal all the cannibalism and who's
gonna die next but that's what a really
good series does you know it demands
that you continue watching so I will
give them props
we're ending it on such a high moment
the thing that stuck out most was Rick
obviously not just because of that WTF
moment with the Marauders but because
he's either reset to that person right
at the beginning of those flashbacks
before he became farmer Rick or he's
more of a monster than ever so far he
still seems like he has a firm grip on
reality and I was really satisfied with
the way he handled the terminus
situation there really is nothing they
could have done about that it looked
like they had almost 50 people with
rifles pointed at them I mean a leader
an archer a samurai and a kid can only
kill so many people at once was anyone
else bummed though that Gareth didn't
give Carl a cool nickname I felt kind of
sad that last moment with Rick is a
really good preview for what the
survivors characters are gonna be like
during season five
no more [ __ ] no more farming just
straight-up ass-kicking I know a lot of
you guys actually commented on how weak
you thought this season was after all
that crazy action during season 3 but I
mean how do you top a walker head
aquarium you just can't do that that's
why I feel like season 4 had to be this
story where all the characters realized
that they can't go back to being normal
people you know never again they come
first
it says the survivors up in this really
nice dichotomy with the creepy terminus
cult so now let me know what your final
thoughts are on the season and what your
biggest questions are going into season
5 like I said I'll be doing season 5
predictions and the Q&A tomorrow I'll
have the winners of the giveaway in the
Q&A video but right now you can click
here to get that I'll add the annotation
as soon as I post it and you can click
here to watch all my other season 4
videos in case you need to rewind just a
little bit anymore WTF moments thank you
so much for watching this has been a ton
of fun I look forward to doing a ton of
season 5 videos high fives
see you guys tomorrow
you